this feels less like a fire more like an
inferno
after weeks of warning this was the town
of bill pin in the Blue Mountains on
Saturday it's normally a tourist area a
farming community but now it's fighting
to save itself but as dramatic as these
pictures are it's seeing what's left
that's truly heartbreaking homes and
businesses have been destroyed
communities are still working out what's
been lost and when did you suddenly
realize it's coming to us right now
about 12:30 yesterday my son said to me
it's coming and Jones has had a farm
here for nearly 40 years last night have
family filmed this Ann's home was
totally surrounded by flames her
grandchildren were evacuated but she
didn't leave could you have left your
house if you'd wanted to no no but
that's right you know boys just said if
I stayed to stay there but that way I
could spot things for them from him
inside the house so that's what I did
but no we're very very lucky
where the colder today than it has been
for the past week and the touch of rain
in the air now to try and get ahead of
these wildfires and they're using all
the resources they have helicopters like
this are picking up water through small
lakes and even swimming pools and
dumping them onto the areas that need it
and right now everywhere feels
vulnerable strong winds are propelling
this fire forward there's not much
moisture at all in the ground we found a
lot of mulch the mulch is just burning
burning through you kick it off the
dirts on fire yeah just in the wind
every day every day it's been playing
havoc with us so it feels a bit
never-ending at the moment at the moment
yeah the priorities are to stop the fire
spread and look after the people the
places and the animals that need help
the back leg this horse badly cut its
leg trying to escape the flames it's
difficult to find a vet who can make it
out here in time
and this is the sense you get here that
this is a moment where neighbors help
each other where volunteers work 24/7 to
confront this familiar yet unpredictable
foe Caterina vittatus Sky News in the
Blue Mountains